our first script is Horsehead curls
fight went on Owens a blackjack dealer
living on a remote reservation recovers
from a night of brutality trying to save
a girl from a sex trafficking ring when
her teenage daughter is kidnapped by the
same organization she fights to not let
her become part of a horrific fate she
knows too well in this scene kaya is
brought into the tribal police station
and questioned after the battered body
of the girl she tried to save the night
before was found in the trunk of her
missing car exterior road day police
chief Ben Mankiller lifts the hood of
the trunk with latex gloves hands khaya
gasps and stumbles backward clothes on
trunk the naked battered and bloodied
bloodied body of the girl from the night
before lays curled among chaos things
she also has a bright red brand on her
ass in the light of day and on someone
else's it's glaringly clear a crude
triangle shape of an oilfield tower with
a pump across the apex do you know her
ko breaks free several feet falls into
the weeds on her hands and knees and
vomits pink frosted pop-tarts the
officer has exchanged glances interior
police station day she sits at a desk in
a small outdated police station wiping
black fingerprint ink from the tips of
her fingers with an alcohol swab Ben
sits across from her tapping on a
computer Lonnie leans up against a wall
nearby and you left it in the parking
lot I told Lonnie it wouldn't start no
jumpers neither it started a write up
when we tried do you usually leave your
keys inside I didn't think I did
Ben nods to Lonnie who produces a
plastic evidence bag and hands it to
Kaia inside is her pink dice keychain
let them did you know the employee
parking lot can't be seen by
surveillance cameras they don't care
about her [ __ ] that's why they stick us
in the back which means we can't see who
took your car or verify that it wasn't
you who is she
the girl she's native it's not one of
ours
maybe Fox River or up a deep water we're
asking around for missing a runaway
juveniles it's a it's a long list I'm
[ __ ] she can be down south or Canada for
all we know she's so young
probably a prostitute a lot of these res
girls choose to doesn't look like it was
her choice to get into my trunk I was
gonna say choose to leave home go into
the cities to find jobs she looks like
Riley I bet she has a family
maybe sisters who were you with last
night nobody I got off work couldn't
stop my car called a few people before
my phone died then I just decided to
walk home someone beat on you your eyes
fresh so was your lip I'm not filing a
report my brother I'm fine I'll talk to
him please he won't remember doing it
and it has nothing to do with whatever
happened with that girl okay yeah I
don't want you wrapped up in bad [ __ ]
and this is real bad [ __ ] I think
someone spotted your car abandoned saw
the keys in it and an opportunity to
dump a mess on a stranger are you gonna
keep it we'll need a process at first
but you'll get it back I take a couple
of days are you gonna tell her about the
other one other what she's probably the
last one another way [ __ ] spreads around
here we think the young lady could be
connected to another homicide we caught
earlier this morning
like this there's two of them we haven't
had a murder up here since 83 it's drugs
vandalism drunk driving but nothing like
this another girl no a tribal member a
white guy
we just called in the feds murders go up
the ladder and we'll work with them or
try at least they think we're in the
dark ages
they'll find the connection if there's
one or just brush it on the rug and
leave us looking like an [ __ ] are
they gonna talk to me too I mean I told
you guys everything you said it yourself
some jerk just used my car for a ride I
got nothing to do with this and this
other guy where was he at
we really can't up at the old Buffalo
house kids hang out there sometimes
bloody as hell so wasn't kids thanks
Lani maybe she has information do you
know I saw the cop cars this morning
when Shelly drove me in bottom is call
someone heard gunshots during fishing
season so I might as well ask you now
officially on the record where were you
around 4:30 a.m. in my bed
right way you should be
and you think the same person I feel
them both yeah all we can think at this
point that it's not you unless your
secret is some undercover Indiana SAS
and blackjack dealer
[Laughter]